welcome to this little session on
performance profiling and
troubleshooting and figuring out when
things go wrong why do they go wrong
i've named it whodunit and so i ran into
a little
what do you call them
smart dress shop earlier to figure out
get some props but all you get was this
little pipe so i hope that's gonna be
all right i'm gonna try and use this to
look smart and look like a detective
throughout i hope you can at least
appreciate that
but so let's get started
ah nice this one doesn't work again
perfect give me a second we can do this
we can find out who did it this time as
well wait it does work
there we go so
before we sort of dive into this whole
thing
it's just nice for you to know a bit
about who i am so you know what i'm
talking about and
maybe know more about what i'm talking
about than i do anyway my name is thomas
hartman it says developer developer
developer although now it's probably
more correct to say deaf relations and
community
because i recently started a job as
developer community manager previously
i've been a developer for a couple years
i've done a bit of everything like from
the front end to the back end
definitely not an expert in any of it
but i like it and it's good fun the most
important thing is i really really like
learning
and that is also sort of how i came into
doing this talk
now it says here that i'm the
co-organizer of the west oslo meetup
group if anyone's interested want to
learn more about that come let me know
i'm sorry i didn't bring any stickers
today i forgot my home so that's not
gonna happen
but
the last point there is quite important
and it says that i'm quite explicitly
not a performance guru
so
why then am i giving this talk if i
don't really know
what i'm talking about and that goes
back to the first point i really really
like learning as a lot of people do i
thought oh you know what that sounds
like a fun thing let's do a talk on it
and then learn how to go about
now where did the idea come from
and to tell you about that i need to
introduce you to
these two fellas
dave rupert and chris coyer of the
shopdog show shopdog show is a podcast
all about finding web design and
development it's run by dave rupert down
on the right and chris coyle up on the
left
now in episode 471 if you want to go
look it up it's about a minute 50.
so it's about half a year ago they said
you know what they were talking about
performance and profiling and suddenly
they said ah it's like it's like a
mystery right it's like the only sort of
mystery we have in our business it's
like whodunit
you know what that sounds really fun
what's this maybe i can use this
to create a talk because it sounds like
something that'd be fun to do
uh and so that's how i ended up here
now
this talk
is language agnostic or at least it's
supposed to be it doesn't say anything
in the brief or the little summary you
got about what language it's in because
it really doesn't matter well it matters
a little bit but the tools we're using
today
something you can use everywhere and not
just in one specific language and it's
all about the mindset and how you
actually work with it
that's what we're looking for
oh and uh before we go any further i'd
just like to tell you that the events
depicted in this talk are fictitious and
that any similarity to any person living
or dead is merely coincidental also no
animals were harmed in the making of
this talk
so
i know i mean i know this usually comes
at the end but no one's going to stay
for the credits anyway so i just thought
i'd get it out of the way yeah
um
so let's talk about the sit-up
let's set the scene and get things going
now because this is sort of a murder
mystery of course it starts
on a dark and stormy night
now if you read the little summary about
the talk you might think oh well i
thought we were on a boat to throw on a
cruise
that's fine if you want to be a
detective on a cruise you be a detective
on a cruise if you want to be in some
big dark gritty city you do that if you
want to be in a french castle cool
whatever detective you want to be now's
the chance to be one
um and in this case
this is actually even before the murder
because you're just sitting there
clucking gleeful away on your keyboard
as you do you know you're a developer
you do things you implement things and
then
the product manager comes through the
door oh oh no
see you used to have a service that
simply took some json transformed it and
spat it back out super simple super easy
but now as product is one to do
they give you additional requirements
now
for the sake of this story this piece of
json
is just less of tickets or objects that
need to be done and so each ticket has
a it's a bit of where you go and get it
what you're getting and who it's
assigned to
as it turns out the less you get in
can't contain duplicates but we don't
like duplicates because a person can
only do one thing at a time so it has to
be deduplicated
next
we like to sort the output we want a
list but when it's sorted
that makes it easier for people to read
through it manually i guess i don't know
why you'd want to do that but it's
product don't question it just do it
last thing ah we need to make some
changes because right now
the target string actually contains
three separate sections we like to split
them out to make it easy to read now
i'll make this clear for you
this is the data that we're getting in
this is the json object that we're
transforming
it's got a target it's got an id and
it's got an assigned to
originally in version one the one that
we had
it does is remove the id because we
don't want to
leak that out to members reading the
data in so it was super simple
transformation just remove id you could
basically just read it in and write it
back out
now we want this
just only do this
so assigned to stays
but you need to split target into three
separate strings so as you can tell you
sort of split it on the colon and you
just say oh it's this field digital in
that field again it's to make it easy to
read and you don't really question it
product says do it you do it
you think ah that's fairly simple right
we can do that pretty quickly
sit down smack something out in like
about an hour write some tests don't
think too much about it
um
and then you hear the screech from down
the hall
because
something really isn't working right
there's been a bit of a murder
you see
it turns out that version 2 is up to 45
times slower
than the actual first implementation
and that is quite a lot
but so when you were implementing this
you thought ah okay well we got this
we've got to do this you've got to do
this some tests here a little bit of
that a little bit of this
you never really gave it much thought
because you know you don't you're not
supposed to think about performance when
you're writing just write whatever it is
simple and easy to read and easy to
understand
and use that
uh you know across the bridge when you
get there performance premature
optimization yada yada yada
now i i just want to say i do not
recommend you think about performance
all the time while writing
that is not really the way to go about
it because you need to know what is
actually
expensive what takes time
but so maybe while you were writing
maybe you did some couple like small
performances you run the same for 10
elements yeah it's fine it's fine it
doesn't really matter
um
but
much like this dog you sort of sat there
and there's just all fire all around you
it's burning you can say this is fine as
much you want
but people
it really
it wasn't fine
not at all
so
we need ourselves
a little investigation
and this is where the fun starts so the
first thing we do
is we gather all the suspects we get
them in together in one room and we look
them all straight in the eye we don't
but we make a list of potential people
now these people do all not exist
they're pulled from this person's not
exist so if they look like someone you
know they're probably not
and if they are i'm very sorry
um these are common things that might
cause performance issues this is not a
definitive list this is not
an exhaustive list it's just here are
things that might cause issues
but
we start this thing right we know our
application a little bit
what can we do what can we know already
may or may not be an issue
first off we know there's there's no sql
there's no network calls we can rule
that out
completely it's fine
second we know the application's single
threaded
that's not an issue
now we also know a little bit about the
application what the language it's
written in
i didn't tell you but i know
that it is written in rust
now what this means is that because rust
has no run time
uh it also doesn't have reflection which
is a runtime thing so it can't be that
also rust isn't garbage collected
so you can't pick up collection
and now we're left with five little
suspects
so now that we have a little list of
people it might be
let's do
some actual benchmarking and figure out
what's going on
so
the term benchmark is
i didn't really know how well i thought
it was but it's apparently from 1838 and
used in a figurative sense in the 1880s
it's fun if you like etymology i do
um anyway what it is is it's a way to
measure the performance of a program
and you should do it by running the
program and then measuring the output
it's got some good pros it gives you a
lot of a
relative overview of how well something
runs so you can run multiple versions of
the same algorithm you can run the same
algorithm on different computers and so
on and so on depending on whether you
want to benchmark hardware or software
but as a con it can also vary a lot
based one thing is what's your hardware
like and the other are you doing
anything else say you're running
benchmarks if you're also playing a
video game on the same computer that's
going to mess things up because you've
only got so much computing power to you
know throw out the benchmarking
so you need
to or you should try and keep it as
stable as you want or as possible
between benchmarks
now if you're using rust
this is just in that case and that's
this is what i've been using here i've
been using criterion
as a benchmarking tool and crit comp as
a way to compare them
now the output of those two things
looks a bit like this
so here
i've benchmarked for
running the program the algorithm
on 10 elements on a hundred elements
on a thousand elements
on ten thousand elements where there's
only 997 unique ones
on
ten thousand elements where there's ten
thousand unique ones
twenty thousand elements where there's
ten thousand unique
and a hundred thousand elements with
maximum roughly a thousand unique ones
and how this works is you've got three
columns the group explains what's been
run v1 is the first version of the
algorithm v2 is the second one
the fact that v1 is all in green means
that v1 was the fastest run for all of
these trials
and so the column directly under v2
means okay this took 1.07 times long or
this took
3.95 times as long to run
and we've got some interesting
properties here so for 10 elements
they're actually roughly the same it
doesn't really matter much right
for a hundred elements suddenly you take
about sixty percent longer
then for a thousand elements you take
almost four times as long
that's really bad
but then suddenly when you have ten
thousand elements
but only a thousand unique ones suddenly
you're not doing that bad anymore after
all
you haven't quite caught up you're still
76 slower
but
it's not as bad so that might give a
little hint as to what might be
happening there but now if you've got 10
000 unique elements
suddenly it takes 15 times longer to run
version two and my favorite is
20 000 elements but only 10 000 unique
ones
it takes 45 times as long to run version
two
now we'll get into this and try and
figure out what happens here but before
we get into looking at actual code and
how it works
i want to bring up another tool that is
useful
for troubleshooting when something goes
wrong and you're not sure exactly where
it went wrong because this thing
happened over multiple commits you don't
know exactly where things got introduced
and that tool
is git bisect
um
and get bisect is a tool that obviously
you need to be working with get but i
assume most people are there are other
options for
version control systems and they're all
valid and they're all cool in their own
right but a lot of people use git i like
it
now get bisect is an implementation or
it's a tool in git that uses binary
search
binary search
is an algorithm
which has a
big o notation that is the worst case
runtime is o log n
now if this doesn't tell you anything
you might not be
familiar with or comfortable with big o
that what it does mean is that if you've
got up to 127 elements it'll take you at
most seven steps to get there
likewise if you've got 255 it's the most
eight steps to find the one
single commit that you were looking for
it's really really useful and gets you
where you need to go really fast
but it only works if the collection is
sorted now
this
talk obviously is about
using it in git and encode in general
but also
i find it to be quite useful in
day-to-day stuff
so my editor's config file is six and a
half thousand lines long
that sounds a bit excessive but
it is what it is
now
it's written in lisp so if there's an
extra closing parenthesis somewhere how
do i know
if i type a parenthesis and then
everything just breaks and i save it i
didn't didn't really check it right you
try try and start theater up later and
just
doesn't work how do you find it when
there's one character
in six and a half thousand lines
binary search works really really well
here too
so
you say oh i don't know where it is you
got a whole file you comment out or you
delete half of it and see does it work
if it does work if everything does one
cool you know the error was in bit you
deleted if it doesn't you know it's in
the first bit you just keep on having
and having and having and you find the
end result really really quickly
now
about get bisect i
know it's a bit scary
it's one of those tools that i've heard
and heard a lot about and people always
saying it's phrases
but i've never really used it before
this
so
it was a fun little thing to learn and
to try and what it does is it's as i
said it lets you search through your
commits
based on the binary search algorithm
what you have to do
is you need
something to tell git is this a good
state or a bad state is this a good
commit or a bad commit does this break
it or does it not
and then at each commit you can check
whether the state is good or bad now
this is quite abstract
and because
i've
never used it before i wrote this talk
and i've heard people talk about it i
wanted to take a minute and just
actually show you how it works so we can
run through it
so there's a little bit of interactive
right here for you or you shouldn't work
with it all
spread it this way all right so
here as you can see we've got a list of
commits on the left
and
we've got a terminal on the right i'm
going to do this in the terminal you can
use a gui for it i'm sure there's
multiple ways to do it
um and we know
that in here
this might take a little bit of building
but
um that's what you do in rust you build
a lot it takes time sometimes hopefully
not too much anyway we know that in this
list of commits right now the tests are
failing
um there is a failing test it says
that's failing tests
and yes i did that that just so we could
do this
but um
let's try and figure out where it's from
so to start a
session you say git bisect start
and now we got it now we're telling it
okay we're doing bisection now help me
out so the first thing we do is we tell
git what's a bad state and we know that
our current commit like the main branch
the tip of the main branch is bad
so we say git by select bad
we also know that on the left here
uh the one that says v1
that one worked we know that much
so we can say okay we can use that we
can say git bisect good
and put in the sha
cool
it now says there's 11 revisions left to
test and it'll take roughly four steps
so it now is automatically checked this
out in
if we jump here
you can see that it can move all the way
down here and it shows us that the top
one is bad
there's a good one and the at is where
we're at we're halfway through
we run cargo test
to see hmm
does this work or does it not
again it's a little bit of building
it's not too bad it's been worse
and then if the tests pass
they do we can say good
git by sight good
then it puts us at the commit that says
add failing tests wow this this sounds
very very
hopeful this might be good
let's try this one out
so if this one's bad
then
we'll be a lot closer
it is bad
who would have thought right
so we can say
git bisect this is bad
now
that means
we're getting closer
git knows it's bad but it doesn't know
it's the first bad one
so obviously you gotta test again oh and
this one's good
and we're really inching towards it here
the last step is the one commit before
the one we found that was bad
so we checked this one too is this one
good or is this one bad
this one's good
that means
that git tells us this is the first bad
commit this is where it happened
now in this case i run a script and
using just regular tests we could have
done this with performance profiling but
that takes a bit longer i thought well
let's just show you how it works also
i did all the steps manually now
thankfully you don't have to
if you have a script that outputs a or
either exits successfully or
unsuccessfully you can have git run that
automatically at every commit as it
checks them out and then find everything
for you
which makes it much quicker but this is
actually how it works i know i would
have appreciated that so i hope some of
you did and if not yeah it's there for
austerity
anyway
using that we can find things
that leaves one
more tool
in our arsenal i mean there's loads of
them obviously but the ones that we're
going to use today and that
is flame graphs
now to talk about flame graphs let's
first talk about
this guy
brendan greg
here he is shouting his lungs out at a
server in the data center
this video is from 2009 i don't know if
any of you seen this but he's actually
in a day center going and really just
yelling at the various servers and the
reason he's doing that is they're
monitoring the performance
so he's got a program that's checking
right performance read performance and
at the same time he's going and shouting
at the servers and what he finds
is it creates a or a notable spike in
the time it takes to write
so showing that
sound waves shock waves can impact the
performance of writing in data center
so
here's a slightly better or a
more flattering photo of him where he's
not just looking into a bunch of servers
uh he brendan greg is a so-called
internationally renowned expert in
computing performance and he's done
loads and loads loads of stuff i think
he's currently working for netflix but
he's also been with sun
oracle and so on
and he's relevant
because he invented fine grass he was
the one who created them
or at least that's what he says and
that's what the internet says
so
a flame graph what is a flying graph
well it's what you see on the right here
apparently he invented them in 2011 when
he was
working on a mind sequel performance
issue and had to understand cpu such
quickly and in depth
flame graphs let you visualize stack
traces
and the way they work is as a graph
there's an x axis that goes along and
there's a y-axis that goes up and down
on the x-axis
the stacks are sorted
alphabetically
and then on the y-axis
you get the stack depth so every time a
function calls another function it adds
layer to the y-axis
um
now the x-axis is not sorted according
to when something's run or how or
how long it takes
it is sorted according alphabetically
but what we do know is that the wider a
box is
the longer it took to run the more time
it's spent on the cpu
and that's what you get to measure with
flame graphs
and just because it's cute
if you flip them upside down they're
called icicle crafts because they sort
of look like icicles this is also really
it's all it's really all a matter of
preference some people like to
start looking at the top and then see
what's got the deepest icicle some
people prefer looking at flames
anyway what happens is
as you see in this full flame chart you
don't have to read this that's fine it's
just it's just a visual
but at the bottom you have wider boxes
and they get narrower and narrower and
narrower and narrower
because everything comes from that first
call right and then so that takes up
spends a whole lot of times debut on
itself and its
descendants
so
what you'll also notice is
some of these are really thin and really
tall
and some
not as tall and quite wide
and that is obviously because how they
work
now there are other options as well to
flame graphs
flame graphs may measure cpu time
sometimes that is not optimal that's not
really what you want to measure because
it might be impacted by a lot of things
such as you're running other processes
or maybe
you suddenly you unplug your laptop and
some battery power and the cpu doesn't
run as fast right
so instead you can do stuff like count
cpu instructions that might be more
appropriate but then again that might
miss things if it's if you're doing um
io or performance sorry i o or
something where it's not on the cpu
where it's not cpu cycle based but it
spends time on the cpu anyway
so we'll be using flame graphs today
because
it's easy it's pretty intuitive and it's
fun
so
now that we've got the tools
we've done a little bit of bisection we
know where we're going
can we crack the case
here
is the flame graph for
when we run with the unique elements
from 10 to 10 000
so that's 10 unique elements 100 unique
elements thousands and 10 000 unique
elements again i don't expect you to be
able to read this i can't read this from
where i'm standing
so i've taken the liberty of
annotating it for you to give you a
rougher view of what's happening
and so going from the left we see that
okay there's a bit of allocations going
on there it's mostly allocating vectors
it's it's a little bit of time it's not
really that much
deserializing apparently that takes a
surprising amount of time it's about
20 or so
serializing
does not take as long
it's good to know
oh but this one deduplication
that's a big one that's about what
half the time roughly it's spent
deduplicating that sounds really really
bad doesn't it that's really bad oh
there's a tiny bit of cloning which is
doing deep copies or copying something
from the heap and putting somewhere else
on the heap
um there's a little bit of converting
what we have into the structs we use and
there's a little bit of sorting but not
much
here uh obviously deduplication is
really really bad but this is for
unique elements right when you've only
got unique gums in the list what happens
when you've got 20 000 elements
but only 10 000 unique ones
yeah
deduplication goes through the roof
everything else is absolutely
unimportant
uh
so that
makes us think ah maybe we should get
the the suspect back in the room
um
and see well okay who can we rule out
now
we know
because i o didn't even appear
it's not i o
there were a little bit of allocations
so maybe they didn't quite like
performance or
but they didn't they definitely didn't
kill it
now d
serializing and deserializing
did take a lot of time absolutely
and there's some deep rooted hatred in
there definitely but
it wasn't the worst thing
now we're left here with algorithms and
data structures they're commonly noticed
or the commonly talked about in
pairs like those who go together and
they do
really influence each other a lot so i
think
that there might be
a little double murder going on
but
so we take them in and
we tie them up we see
trying to see who really
killed performers here
and
it was me
i wrote the algorithm so obviously i'm
the one who did it
um it was me all along and i would have
gotten away with it two it wasn't for
you meddling kids
so
that thing
always remember it's not really the
functions it's about what you do and how
you measure it and all do that but the
good thing
in software
when something dies we can bring it back
let's see what we can do
to fix things
i did not bring a firefighter uniform
but so i'll stick with my pipe instead
at least we will try to fix it now
as we saw
the really really worst thing was
deduplication
click
can we fix that here is the first
version of the algorithm it's in in or
this is in version two so the first the
duplication
now i'm not going to go super in depth
here but
what we do is we get a list or a vector
as you call them in rust of the input
elements we then take this reverse it
we allocate a new vector and then for
every element in the input we check does
this
id exist
in the output vector
if so
don't do anything and if it doesn't
insert it obviously this is going to
give us a really bad run time it's a
quadratic one time so that's o and
square
that's going to take a lot of time um
there's also a bit of cloning and
unwrapping going on before sorting so
this is just really really bad
but
can we
how best to get rid of this thing is
in rust if you want to sort or if you
want to duplicate a vector the best way
is to have it sorted but we can't sort
it because we need it by time instead
so because the vector has all the events
in the order that they happened
we can't sort them by the assignee
before we de-duplicate them so we need
to de-duplicate and then sort
but
thing is
data structures right aren't they great
we've got something called sets or maps
and they have as their property they can
only contain one element per or they
have unique elements right you can't
have two of a thing in a set
and it might be kind of two things at
the same key so using a map just pushing
everything into a map
we can say okay well
i'll get a new map
and then check has this thing been
inserted into the map before if it has
don't do it
now i said that we
because the vector is time ordered and
we want the last elements because they
have the right assignees
we need to iterate from the back we
don't have to reverse the vector because
again sorry this is a bit rust specific
but rust lets you iterate from the start
or from the end so if you just start
start at the end just iterate all the
way around
we just need to check whether it
contains the element yet or not
obviously you can't say if it is
contained then replace them and i tried
that originally
turns out i mean it's faster
but checking whether the map contains
the key before trying to insert it
gains even more speed
now doing it this way you end up putting
it into a map then back into a list and
then sorting the list
that sounds like a lot of work it
doesn't sound amazing but
or at least so i thought so i had a good
idea
how about we use an ordered map right
because
well it's like a hat map but it's sorted
by descending value
i thought ah that's really clever thomas
you've cracked the case this is a good
one turns out it wasn't very good at all
um because the time you spend
on insertion just is too much it takes
too long to sort it when things go in
so i tried many many iterations of this
because it makes sense
it would be so nice we could just have
it sorted automatically
but nah
it doesn't work doesn't work
another thing
uh and this
gets to when talking about stack and the
heap
and rust string types
um
the question is rhetorical how many
types does it have i don't really know
but the ones you do see in common usage
are string and stir that's what i got
that's what i'm going to call them the
sdr stir
and
these
have different purposes
the string
lives on the heap the stir
lives on the stack
now just
very quickly
yeah uh the heap
is you need to allocate stuff on heat
that's where you've got large we don't
know how big they are where they can
grow they can shrink and all that stuff
that's why the string
lives on the because you can grow it you
can mutate it you can do what you want
with it
a stir
is just a pointer
now we know how large a pointer is so we
can put it on the stack we don't need
allocate memory for it because we know
exactly how large it is
that makes it a lot lighter to work with
and easier
now the funny thing is a stir can point
to a string but it isn't a string
the ampersand in the name stir is
because it's a reference so you don't
really own it
again sorry this is a bit sort of rusty
but the important thing here is
you don't need to if if you have a
string already you don't need to clone
it and create an allocate new memory and
put it on the heap you can say oh i'm
just pointing to this string this is
where i'm at
and the
sort of genius thing here as well you
don't need to point to the whole string
you can point to little sections it's
like you create a little window
here is this bit of the string that i
want to point at
and then you can take a large string and
create many small ones
and the small ones will be super light
so
creating windows in the original version
the the target struct where we had the
location the object id and the code
all used strings
now strings as i said live on the heap
they are owned you need to allocate for
them and you don't really know how large
they are
so this is why on the flame graph the
allocation bit just completely went away
obviously it wasn't as big as
duplication but i think that might you
might take away so instead of using
strings and allocating and copying and
doing all that stuff we can just point
to where it comes from we got this big
json string note this is between these
two indices in the string
and work with it that way the weird
apostrophe a here by the way this is rus
lifetimes if you don't know don't worry
about it it's complicated but useful
when you get used to it
so
cool we got windows
but because we're doing a lot of string
manipulation or not manipulation but
we're cutting a lot of strings right
we've got like 10 000 strings coming in
and each one we've got a split
so i thought
how long is the piece of string and how
long today to cut it
so we're splitting this string over here
or over there
into three and we're splitting it on
colon so i thought how about we actually
try and write nc
profile that as well see what's faster
i came up with
four
sensible ways of doing that i'm not
going to
really go in to explain it to you
because
it's quite code specific we can look at
them later if you want to
but it's two main ways one
is using a string split method you say
i'll split the string on colons then you
iterate over it because you get a list
back and you can iterate and go give me
this one give me this one give me that
one
the other version
is the more
basic perhaps you go
and go in and look for the index of the
first colon you go in and look for the
index of the last colon
and you go and you just use you just cut
the slices use substrings right you say
oh well it's between this and between
that
and
it turns out the last version where you
manually go and find the index of the
characters that you want
is quite a bit faster so the slowest
version
is
what three times as slow as the fastest
version and the funny thing is uh this
which is just in this case it's not a
general thing
that the height of the flame graph the
flames
actually correspond to the run time so
the the one that takes the longest one
has the tallest bit and so on and so on
so
now that we know this
we've made a couple changes can we
return back to the flame graph and see
how
things have changed
and this
is what it looks like in the new version
uh here is annotated for you
as we can see
now deserialization takes up a lot more
space than it did previously it's almost
half the graph right and then there's a
little bit of serialization and there's
some sorting going on
the other bits are
inserting into the hashmap and that's
mainly actually the duplication
insertion
and there's finally there's converting
the input into struct and creating the
data structure we need
what's interesting here is i haven't
touched the serialization or
deserialization code i use a pretty
standard library in rust for that
it is the go-to i'd say it's called
survey
it's really really good but it takes
time now that might just be the cost of
entry right because at some point you
can't really go faster
but because we haven't touched
deserialization or serialization code
we can put this up against the flame
graph we had before
now we know that in this case
uh the deserialization should be roughly
it should take as long in time so cpu
time should be as much but that means we
can get relatively
see what's happened so before
it took about yeah 20 of the time spent
serialization and the rest was on other
stuff now it's about 50. so that means
that
while we don't get exact numbers
it means that everything else has to be
done a lot lot faster
and this is sort of
what happens because in the end you know
there's always
always
going to be slowdowns when you do more
the more things you want to do the more
computation you have to do obviously
it's going to take longer so that's
something you've got to take in account
it's always going to be a thing but you
can
try and find out what's causing issues
might be causing issues
and
find things you can do or maybe things
that he cannot do as well
so
i ran the benchmarks again
they're not sorted as beautifully as
they were before i'm sorry about that
but so we've got this group here and
we've got four versions
version one is the one that just strips
id and then prints it out again or
literally all it does
serialize it then deserialize it again
version two
that's the horrible horrible horrible
one with the absolutely terrible
duplication code
version three
is mostly what we've been talking about
but
the difference between version 3 and
version 4
is how we insert into the hashmap
whether we
check
first before we insert an iterate from
the back
or whether we just insert again whenever
we find the new key so in version three
we iterate through the vector
in order from top
and you say ah i just just insert this
and rust will
if the key exists already rust will swap
it out and put the new object there
instead now in version 4 we go from the
back which check for the key first
the interesting thing to note here is
there's seven benchmarks
version one wins in three of them
version four wins in four of them this
is not to say that version four is
better let's look at what they're
actually doing
so the top one
twenty thousand elements ten thousand
unique ones right
this is one of the ones that version
four does better
uh version one is slightly slower but
remember what we found out
that
serialization and deserialization takes
a lot of time version one did not do any
deduplication it just printed everything
out again
so when you print out 20 000 elements
and write those to a file
that's going to take you longer than it
is to deduplicate and write the 10 000
elements out to a file
similarly for 10 elements
that's such a small sample that i don't
really know
it's not really relevant and if you look
at the the plus minus ones
version one goes down to about 35
whereas version 4 goes down to about
38 so it doesn't really matter such
small sizes
at 100 elements it starts to become
noticeable
because we're all unique
and then version one
faster than the version 4 but not by a
lot so version 4 is about 13 slower
compared to version 2 which here
took an extra 60
better 1000 elements similar story
it's about 44 slower compared to
four times slower that is 300 percent
slower that version 2 was definitely
better
again
there's no version four is faster for
ten thousand and a hundred thousand
elements when there's only a thousand
unique ones
serialization right
and then finally when there's ten
thousand unique ones
version one is sas freaking but not by a
whole lot so it takes 30 longer to do
all of that extra processing
compared to the original which was 15
times
so
like as a summary
the less you do
the faster it's going to be the less
things you have to calculate obviously
faster and that's why version one always
wins when there's only unique items
when there are duplicates it's going to
be and you need to get them out
obviously before it's going to be faster
so all this to say that you need to know
what your code is doing
and what it needs to optimize for you
need to know what the hot code paths are
so you know what it's worth optimizing
so the allocation thing the string thing
i did
it's not really worth a whole lot but to
me it was funny it was something i
wanted to look into
but obviously the deduplication is that
on the whole thing a thing we could do
here
because serialization takes that long
is look into are there better ways of
serializing are there better serializers
these serializers
i keep messing those up by the way i
mean deserialization because that's the
biggest one but serialization two
can we make that faster this is an
external library do are there faster
ones that serve the same purpose
and so it's all about trying to figure
out what you need to do
for your code to run where it is but now
i've given you
a couple tools and we've looked at them
and had a little bit of fun a couple
laughs and that's really all i can give
you today so
thank you very much for coming along and
any questions and stuff i'm happy to
take them
generally upload myself should it's a
bit dodgy
all right
any questions at all no
all right watch case thank you very much
enjoy the rest of your day enjoy the
rest of the conference as much as you
can
and have a great weekend